gracias a ron y qué significa la muerte
de al zawahiri para la estrategia contra
el terrorismo de joe biden
hola muy buenas
más que nada esto lo que significa es
que se cierra o ya se siente un
sentimiento de cerrar este capítulo de
septiembre 11 de los ataques terroristas
sobre eeuu porque al zawahiri estuvo muy
ligado a bin laden
se cree que ayudó poco pero con la
planeación de los ataques terroristas
contra eeuu y obviamente era el líder
ahora visible de al qaida o sea que esto
ayuda a cerrar este capítulo ayuda a dar
ese sentimiento de cerrar este capítulo
desde septiembre 11 no es el fin de al
qaeda ni muchísimo menos queda para
seguir se dice que ahora el que era
hasta ahora 'número dos' que se supone
que según las fuentes de inteligencia
que está en irán va a tomar ahora el
liderato de la organización y siempre
aclaró está va a seguir la organización
va a seguir aunque debilitada va a
seguir y también vas a seguir claro
hasta los posibles lobos solitarios
personas que se sienten inspirados o que
son simpatizantes de al qaeda siempre
pueden atacar en los países occidentales
por lo menos esto ayuda a eliminar a un
blanco visible a un blanco que era
simbólico y visible de la organización y
ayuda a cerrar este capítulo desde
septiembre 11 bueno cuando hablaba de
los lobos solitarios se quería también
preguntarle sobre esta advertencia que
lanza el departamento del estado de
posibles ataques después de la muerte de
este líder de al-qaeda que tan alerta
deben estar los ciudadanos y las
instituciones estadounidenses
bueno pues ahora mismo estamos en un
peligro de
peligro alto deberían estar muy alertas
hay que entender cómo funcionan estas
organizaciones tienen células
organizadas más que nada en los países
musulmanes en el norte de áfrica en el
medio oriente tienen su indolencia
también en malasia tienen células
organizadas que pertenecen al grupo que
obviamente pertenecen y se comunican con
el liderato esos son los que usualmente
planean ataques de corte mayor o más
peligrosos contra las fuerzas armadas
contra instituciones contra políticos
etcétera pero también hay cientos sino
miles de simpatizantes que no están
encuadrados dentro de la jerarquía de la
organización pero que si se sienten
inspirados y son simpatizantes de la
organización y esos son más peligrosos
de hecho porque esos
mantienen un perfil muy bajo son muy
difícil de identificar para la policía y
las agencias de inteligencia y eso se
encuentran en todas partes no solamente
los países de mayoría musulmana del
norte de áfrica se encuentran en francia
se encuentran españa se encuentra en
inglaterra en alemania etcétera y esos
también podrían actuar son los llamados
lobos solitarios o sea que hay que estar
muy alerta muy afecta tanto a nivel
militar en los países musulmanes como
también en los países occidentales la
policía de la fuerza de inteligencia
tienen que estar muy alertas ahora mire
la operación que le dio muerte al
zawahiri se dio en afganistán es donde
eeuu y ya no tiene una presencia
permanente en qué contexto se llevó a
cabo el operativo y está washington en
su opinión en capacidad de monitorear la
presencia de extremistas en ese país
pues obviamente no todos los extremistas
pueden ser monitora
pueden seguir seguidos por las agencias
de inteligencia pero siempre hay en la
cia siempre hay en la enee sea siempre
hay en la vía y siempre hay
células muy especializadas que utilizan
y utilizan siguen utilizo la
inteligencia de señales para seguir los
pasos los movimientos de estas grandes
figuras de estos grandes líderes ya sea
de al qaeda ya sea de edades del estado
islámico ya sea del haqqani network
siempre esos son seguidos son muy
difíciles de esconderse por decirlo así
ya eeuu no tienen una presencia está en
afganistán yo estuve en afganistán
cuatro veces lo conozco muy bien el país
ahora ya no estamos allí ya nos ya nos
salimos de allí ya nos rendimos y nos
fuimos de allí pero siempre es tarde la
inteligencia de señales siempre hay
fuentes humanas de inteligencia humana
que se reporta eeuu y eeuu la cia y la n
sea más que nada siempre siguen los
teléfonos celulares los emails las
fuentes
de los que quieren hablar y siempre van
a tratar de seguir por lo menos al
liderato a liderar estas organizaciones
siempre trataremos de seguirlo esto fue
una operación de la cia no fue una
operación militar no fue del pentágono y
fue la cia que utilizó los drones y que
utilizó dos misiles hellfire para acabar
con trabajar agua o sea que yo creo que
la inteligencia va a seguir siguiendo
los pasos de los grandes líderes de esta
organización es